so I guess before i get into likes stuff
on mobile specifically stepping back for
a second the the main issues we tend to
see in usable security tend to just
stand from two different areas so one is
that users are confronted with so many
different security decisions that they
become habituated to all the security
decisions in the future the second
problem that we tend to see is that
oftentimes the security decisions that
developers ask users to make users are
just completely unqualified to be making
those decisions and there's a lot of
stuff that we can learn from looking at
the classic hazard avoidance literature
so looking at the hazard avoidance
literature there's sort of a hierarchy
of interventions so you know the best
thing you can do when faced with a
hazard is simply eliminate that hazard
so that you know people don't encounter
it sometimes you know we can't do that
so the next best thing is to guard
against the hazard so that people are
less likely to succumb to that hazard
and then only in the worst case when
none of that is available we use
warnings and too often we see in
computer security that we jump to just
using warnings when there's probably a
lot of other things that we can do such
as doing a better job of eliminating
hazards or helping users make better
decisions without just throwing
information at them and asking them to
you know click either one of two buttons
so to give you an example of some of
these decisions and how it has to do
with mobile one common threat is SMS
charges so a lot of malware on mobile
devices will in the background send a
paper text messages which could run up
someone's phone bill so maybe a user
gets a phone bill for several thousand
dollars all to maybe one number and now
they want to look at their phone to
figure out what application might have
called this so on Android what you would
do is open up your applications you get
this list of
scroll down to settings from there click
settings uh now you have to find the
application button you click that and
then manage applications click there and
it lists all the applications installed
then you go through every application
you click one application it brings up
this application settings you have to
know to scroll to the bottom to the
permissions and now it shows you all the
abilities for this particular
application so this is that there's a
joke about this being a 12-step process
somewhere in here but imagine you know
user have to do this for every single
application that's installed in order to
figure out which one might be the one
that's sending the offending messages so
this still isn't really going to tell
them with any certainty it's just going
to tell them the subset of applications
that are granted this ability so there
are better ways of doing this so what I
was gonna talk about is how choice
architecture and how we present these
different mechanism security and privacy
mechanisms to end users has a profound
impact on how they care for ver
information and how they're aware of
what applications might be doing with
their information so mobile security is
really interesting because it sort of
become the primary computing platform
for a lot of people so in this country
half of people have smartphones well I
octa bout you know malware in this
example with you know an unwanted app
maybe sending SMS messages in the
background this actually happens pretty
infrequently and instead the much bigger
problem that we see is grey ware and by
grey where I mean applications that a
user outright installed and wanted on
their phone and sees some benefit from
having but that might be doing something
unexpected in the background such as you
know leaking some of their personal data
which might make them feel uncomfortable
and so in this talk I was going to talk
about some of these problems and how the
architectures on these mobile systems
have a lot of problems with making users
aware of how personal information might
be used and how a lot of the stems from
the specific permission mechanisms that
each
platform chooses to implement and how
having a lot more thought in turn in
terms of granting permissions might
actually improve these scenarios and
also how to eliminate the habituation
problem maybe in some cases we just
shouldn't give the user the option to
you know approve or deny these
permission requests and then in the
cases where permission requests are
probably necessary how we can design
these interactions better so that when
people are getting these warning
messages about how personal data might
be used they can make a much more
informed decision so looking at current
problems some of the early work I did in
this area was looking at android so in
android when you install an application
at in step the installation time you the
user is presented with a list of all the
abilities that that application is
requesting so the permissions and there
are over a hundred of them in current
versions of Android and so when they
install an application they get a bunch
of these little boxes that say you know
things like this one is requesting
internet access but you can imagine lots
of other ones such as you know maybe
vibrating the phone sending text
messages taking pictures that sort of
thing and the user is then faced with
the decision of you know continue to
install thereby granting all these
abilities or you know discontinuing the
installation so we want to look at
comprehension so do users actually
understand what these things mean and
also when they're presented with each of
these permission requests do they
understand what you know capabilities
there then granting the application so
we did a comprehension survey we did
this online we used AdMob to recruit
people and so AdMob is a mobile
advertising platform they're both
thereby guaranteeing that everyone who
was participating was on an Android
device which means that you know
ostensibly they're familiar with Android
so we wanted existing Android users so
we had about 10 of these permission
requests and we randomize them so that
every participant got three of them at
random
and we just ask them we showed them a
screenshot we asked you know if an
application has granted this what does
that enable the application to do so in
this case we have network access and so
the correct answers here would be
loading advertisements and sending
information the application server and
from this what we found was that on
average of the three questions people
got half a question correct and so you
might say well you know this was online
it was unsupervised maybe they were just
randomly guessing well we can you know
calculate the expected value of random
guessing and then do a you know a
chi-square test and we find that you
know despite this being relatively low
it's still significant higher
significantly higher than the expected
value which is I think roughly about
point two questions out of the three
that said there were only eight
participants out of the 308 who managed
to get all three of them correct the
majority of participants couldn't answer
any of these correctly again these are
existing Android users so there are some
room for improvement here we did this
online this was completely quantitative
and so we want to do a follow-up
laboratory experiment to get the
qualitative data on why comprehension
was so low we recruited 24 people from
craigslist to come in and we had them do
three different tasks so one was we just
had them install two different
applications of their choice we gave
them scenarios and so to search through
the online store to pick applications
based on these scenarios but other than
that we gave them no guidance on what
applications to install and we observed
them to see whether they would pause on
that permission request screen to try to
read it or whether they would you know
choose to discontinue installing the app
based on that screen and then finally in
the third task we had them open up the
settings panel on their device for an
application of their choice that they
use regularly and then looking at those
the permissions that were granted to
that application of their choice that
they use regularly could they tell us
whether or not that application has the
ability to send SMS messages
and so we found was that during the
installation task fewer than twenty
percent of our participants stopped at
that screen to actually look at it we
suspect this is probably an upper bound
because they were in the laboratory they
knew that they were being observed so
maybe they you know did the task with a
lot more diligence than they might at
home and then the other task about
answering the question about could they
could the app that very familiar with
send SMS messages a majority
participants couldn't answer that
question correctly even though they were
looking at the list of granted
permissions yeah how did you measure
that is that you just looked at whether
people spend more than 15 seconds
rhiannon whether they so basically you
know people were bitching through so
when you install an app there's an
install button and then that screen
comes up right after you click install
and there's another button in a similar
spot so you know over eighty percent of
the people just sort of click twice to
go right through that screen and when we
asked them you know afterwards they said
oh yeah they thought that was just like
a license agreement so they notice get
past that we observed then yeah so they
hid in the lab and you know we're next
to them as they were installing
applications so based on the qualitative
results we had a couple suggestions on
how the user experience could be
improved so one was that people were
just you know habituated to seeing these
requests with every app installation
regardless of what the risks associated
with those permissions were so too many
requests so maybe you know users should
only be prompted when absolutely
necessary when there's an actual risk
many people were simply unaware so again
the screen appears after they click the
install button many people thought that
that was just sort of a license
agreement and the very was supposed to
click through it there are also many you
know cognitive biases that might have a
you know might have been at play here so
maybe choice supportive bias after
clicking the install button they didn't
want to you know read
that decision that they just made to
install the application and so maybe you
know presenting this information at a
different point in the the interaction
would have yielded different results so
maybe before Vic lik install it shows
the permissions or maybe at runtime when
the data is actually needed by the
application maybe then would be a better
time the the last problem was that we
observed with the SMS thing when we had
them use an application that they were
already familiar with the reason why
most of them got that wrong is that they
saw things like a request for network
access and they didn't know that there
was a separate permission for sending
SMS data they thought maybe that's part
of network access and so in this case
there's so many different permissions
that really knowing the entire set of
permissions is necessary to know what
permissions an app is not requesting and
when you have you know 100 some
different permissions that's obviously
unreasonable so you know in this case
there are many different ways of
granting permissions on mobile devices
and this also applies for you know
desktop platforms as well in the case of
Android there were you know their
install time warnings this is how it
appears in I guess the more current
versions of Android the advantage of
having the install time warnings for
doing the permissions is that it's
adaptable to you know a great basically
every permission you can do this because
you're just you know you need a little
space a little space for text here and
you have the text to describe the
permission it's also useful for granting
future abilities so you know these are
granted and install time the application
can then use that ability anytime in the
future because it's already been granted
the drawbacks to this they're mostly
that there's the limited real estate so
you know on your average device it's
about these dimensions you could really
only fit three different permission
requests on that screen you're then
relying on the user to know that they
have to scroll down the screen to view
additional permissions and so those are
easy to overlook also when this is part
of
of you know the installation flow it's
also easy to overlook because there are
a lot of other decisions that they're
making at that time and the last problem
is that they lacked they lack contacts
so when you're granting future abilities
you have no idea in what sort of
situations these abilities are actually
going to be used because it's at install
time so when an application say asks for
location access and install time you
know maybe to some people that would
signal location specific features which
might be desirable but it could also
mean maybe behavioral advertising is
being done based on location which is
you know something that people might
find undesirable when it's done it you
know a priori here there's really no way
of distinguishing the two so we could do
use runtime warnings to try and convey
some of this information and the
advantage that these have over the
installation warnings is that they have
contacts so you know the user is
actually doing something in the
application when this screen is
displayed so they might have you know
click something and Yelp to view
restaurants near them and so then when
they get a request for you know Yelp is
requesting location access they have
some idea of why Yelp is requesting
location access likewise you know if
you're using angry birds and all of a
sudden it requests location it's not
immediately obvious and so maybe that's
being used for something else and then
the user might have a better idea of why
they want to you know decline giving
giving it that access another nice thing
about runtime warnings is that they can
be dynamic so in the case you know here
maybe we have bluetooth pairing so in
this case because it's at runtime we can
show the name of the device that's
trying to pair with whereas if this were
done at install time basically there's
no way of doing that you can't predict
in the future what all the devices would
be these have dropped drawbacks as well
so you know the primary one is
habituation so users tend to see these
as a barrier to the primary task they're
doing something all of a sudden this
dialog appeared I need to swat this away
so that I can continue doing what I was
already you know trying to do so
Microsoft got a lot of flack for this in
Windows Vista so they have this user
account control whenever an application
required and east
elevated privileges it would throw one
of these runtime warnings and basically
trained people to click continue
whenever they saw one of these so this
begs the question maybe we could use
some sort of mechanism that doesn't
interrupt the users flow so that these
aren't seen as a barrier to the primary
task so you know one thing apples doing
is curation so in the itunes store when
you download an app there aren't any
sort of permission requests because
there's a screening process if you're a
developer your app is reviewed by some
sort of opaque process and that's the
problem is you know their you know their
goals goal is to try and review these to
prevent you know security and privacy
issues for end users without asking end
users to dedicate you know effort to
making decisions often incorrectly on
their own but the problem with this is
that the process is completely opaque so
you know it's relying on humans to do
the review they could automate this but
a lot in a lot of the cases these things
are really hard to detect automatically
so there's some you know human review
board which of course you know is then
subject to human error and some of it is
you know very subjective so you know
people probably remember the path fiasco
or Fiasco's because this happened twice
path is the popular social networking
app it turns out the iOS app two years
ago three years ago was accessing users
address books on their iOS devices which
was against apple's terms of service now
obviously if it's against the Terms of
Service one would think that as part of
the curation process that would have
been detected it wasn't and the app was
used by millions of users this happened
again with path a year or two ago was
another thing that it was doing which
should have been caught by the review
process but wasn't so there are problems
with that it's also resource intensive
if you're you know hiring humans to be
looking at millions of apps so there are
other approaches that you know don't
involve the user being interrupted so
trusted you I is
when I say trusty you I I mean system
widgets that are drawn by the OS so in
this case you know maybe for some
ability the developer specifies where on
the screen a system drawn widget should
appear such as a button or some sort of
chooser and then the only way of
granting that ability is that through
interacting with that system drawn
widget in this case you know a malicious
app can't spoof that to try and get the
permission because the spoofed one
doesn't actually get the data so you
know imagine sending SMS messages if the
only way of sending SMS on the platform
is through this system drawn button it's
relying on the user clicking on that
button as part of their interaction with
the application it's not you know
interrupting them it's part of the flow
here so you know you can imagine other
ones may be with you know for using the
camera there's a shutter button and so
then the only way of taking photos is by
clicking that shutter button then it's
part of the users flow there's no way of
spoofing those buttons to capture the
data anyway and the users not being
interrupted another advantage of using
trusted UI components is then granting
subsets of the data so you can have
choosers for instance you know in this
picture we have maybe a calendar widget
an application wants to add something to
the user's calendar a chooser comes up
now you know it's not a binary choice
the user can you know make adjustments
before the data is accessed by the
system you know you can imagine things
like this with you know accessing photos
in an application and you know this is
nothing new so we have this on you know
desktop operating system so usually when
you open a file those all those widgets
are drawn by the OS developers don't
usually implement the you know the file
open or file save widgets these have you
know drawbacks though so you know in
order to be you know part of the user is
flow you can't have what i refer to as
asynchronous requests and what I mean is
things that are triggered by the users
environment so you know imagine you know
you have some app for some Wi-Fi
provider you know certainly you could
have a button that issues a callback
that says you know when i'm with in rain
change then join this network but that's
no longer part of the users flow because
now they're making a decision ahead of
time and obviously too you know if
you're having them push the button
frequently until they're within range
that's no longer you know it's still not
part of our natural flow so this you
know there are some you know limits to
what trusted you I can be used for and
then finally there's what I refer to as
implicit access so in some cases maybe
that the risk the risk associated with a
request is just so minimal maybe it
should just be granted without bothering
the user and in this case you know we
should have maybe some sort of
attribution mechanism so that when
permissions are granted automatically to
minimize situation if something does go
wrong there should be information about
what app was responsible so provenance
so in this case you know maybe changing
the time on your device you're not going
to want to have like a runtime warning
every time an app wants to maybe update
the clock you can think of some you know
James bond-esque plot that relies on
changing the time on someone's phone but
that seems really unrealistic and in
most cases it's pretty benign and the
damage can be undone once it's
identified so in this case maybe we
could just annotate the settings panel
to say what was the last application to
modify that setting so that if it's you
know if it's abused someone knows which
applications responsible they can remove
that application so looking at all these
permission granting mechanisms if our
utility function is to only interrupt
the user when absolutely necessary we
can sort of build a hierarchy here so
you know least utility is the install
time warning because users see these
every single time and you know the best
case would be the implicit access where
users aren't eating asked at all to make
any decisions and I argue that one of
the big problems that we see on
platforms today is that most operating
systems just pick one permission granted
mechanism and roll with that one for all
the decisions so in the case of Android
it's all install time warnings on iOS
they actually have there are five
current runtime warnings and the rest is
completely opaque to the user
but maybe we should choose which
permission mechanism to use based on
risk or something else researchers
people who are I guess oh yes yes that's
a much broader question I think that one
of the big problems that we have is that
yeah there are there certainly
mismatched incentives which is a big
issue but I think one of the things
that's really overlooked is that
developers are under a lot of different
constraints and security is just a very
small portion of that and so frequently
you know they just want some sort of
guidance on how to implement it and
right now there's you know you know well
we'll just make a warning and let the
user deal with that but I think that if
there's you know some guidance saying
that this is you know here the current
best practices use will be more
satisfied and also you know in some to
some extent the companies are sort of
incentivized to do the right thing so if
you know one platform has a reputation
for apps you know abusing data then you
know they're going to take a hit on that
so it's in the company's best interest
to keep their users happy and feel like
you know variant control of how the
personal information is shared doing
this company is this love themself or
the applications because I'm sorry lat
forms because applications and compose
at the same agreed mine okay everything
I'm talking about in this talk is at the
platform level I mean so the platform
can make these design decisions that you
know say the only way of getting access
to this data is by using this mechanism
then the application developers have no
choice but to abide by that yeah and so
we reasoned about this and we came up
with this flowchart on how to make
decisions about which permission
granting mechanism to use based on risk
and a few other things so you know the
first step is this notion that we're
calling revert ability so if a device
makes a change can the device be
reverted to a previously known good
so maybe you know one example that is
say changing the time you know obviously
you can change the time back little harm
is likely done in that case grant the
permission maybe have some attribution
mechanism so that you know users can
undo it if it's abused but you know
maybe you know the damage can't be
undone so then the question is severity
so is this just an annoyance or is there
going to be some lasting harm by
granting this permission automatically
and if it's really just an annoyance so
you can imagine something like maybe you
know making noise or vibrating the
device you know you thought you could
probably think of all sorts of you know
freak occurrences where that could cause
lasting damage but for the most part
that's just an annoyance and you know
once it stops the the harm is you know
over in that case yeah implicitly grant
the permission and again have the
attribution mechanism but if none of
that applied then the question is did
the user initiate the you know the
action through their natural flow with
you know with the app and if so trusted
uicomponent if not you know maybe it's
something that's generated by the
environment you know one of these
asynchronous requests if a subset of the
data can be you know granted or you know
we can apply some sort of granularity to
what's being requested then you know you
can have some sort of shoes or widget
from trusted you I as well if none of
that applies then the question is is the
permission needed in the future if so
the only way of doing that would be at
install time so you know a scenario
there might be you have some security
software so that if your phone is ever
stolen you can go to a website and it
wipes the device obviously you're not
going to want have some sort of runtime
warning come up asking the person who
now possesses your device if they really
want to you know destroy the data on it
that has to be granted in the future if
it can be done runtime then you know
have some sort of runtime warning or
confident you know confirmation dialog
otherwise you know we're stuck doing at
install time so going through the whole
spectrum of different Android
permissions we can actually really
reduce the number of user interactions
here so you know prior to applying this
flow
a chart to the Android permission system
100 percent of the abilities are granted
and install time but using this
methodology we can reduce that to about
six percent of the permissions and in
fact a majority of them could just be
implicitly granted and we can have some
sort of attribution mechanism to tell
users you know this happened if you're
interested of course this is just
looking at the total number of
permissions and this doesn't reflect how
frequently each of this each of these
permissions are exercised that's
actually a project that we're working on
this summer we're hooking those api's
and actually logging them in the field
to look at how frequently different
permission permissions are requested on
devices so we can reduce a lot of these
and so the next part of the talk is
looking at what are these attribution
mechanisms that we might want to explore
so we're referring to this as begging
forgiveness instead of asking for
permission because we're you know
telling people after the fact what app
was responsible for a particular change
so the question is are these really
necessary well it turns out they are
because when we did an online survey and
we asked people about how they'd go
about pinpointing the cause of a
misbehavior on their device only about
only twenty-two percent of our
participants understood that
applications running in the background
could be just as responsible for a
device this behavior as applications
running in the foreground the corollary
to this is the vast majority of users
simply you know when something this
penis behaves on their phone they simply
blame whichever app happen to be running
in the foreground that they could
actually see which is probably likely to
be incorrect um now so that was just
like everything reliable um yes so it
depends i mean so the scenario that we
were asking about is like data overages
for instance they would you know they
say oh well you know i was using this
app last so that must be responsible
I'll get into that a little more later
but I we didn't look at it from that
perspective when we asked about specific
miss behaviors
I'm sure the answer is different when
this has to do with like instability
things crashing I was listening yet yeah
that's cause often by applications or
drivers but yeah no I agree that's not
something we asked about yeah yeah I
think instability is probably one issue
we were talking about you know I other
things that could be controlled by the
permission systems so any answering yeah
it is a different answer that people
have found to that question on desktop
OS is prior switch pushing about whether
or not they blame the OS or the
application due to something like um
yeah I think I mean that's the that's
the point so in I guess one before
Microsoft I guess this was when did they
start I was a patch tuesday that was
like 10 years ago the big trustworthy
computing push it was because the OS was
getting blamed for instability which was
largely caused by poorly written device
drivers written by third parties we
haven't I haven't done a direct
comparison so I can't really speak to
that but I can you know I can definitely
say that from anecdotally on the desktop
people were much more you know people
just blame the OS the window good idea
that on a desktop OS it's natural that
things are multitasking and they're
visually taking up yeah spades are like
simultaneously there are verses on the
fundament you're doing this one thing
whether that affects me that's a really
good question yeah we haven't explored
that um so we want to look at you know
if we're going to start adding new
attribution mechanisms to the OS
obviously we don't want to rely on a big
you know user education campaign because
that's really costly and really these
are just be new features that appear in
the OS we want to see if users would
discover these and so to explore this we
looked at new features that have
appeared in Android over the time to see
how quickly users become aware of these
types of audit mechanisms so right at
the time that we were doing this android
for had been out for about a year and it
added this new feature for data usage so
in the settings panel you can click this
and it brings up a panel it shows your
the graph of your data usage over the
past month and if you scroll down it'll
show the applications by order of how
much data they use so you know this is
not something that they were you know
publicizing or training users on and so
we wanted to see given that this has
been in deployment for about a year our
users aware of this and would they take
advantage of it so you know we provided
a scenario and asked how they would you
know investigate a data overage and we
had an open-ended text box for them to
describe what they would do on their
device and then we split people based on
what OS they used on their device and
what we found was that almost three
quarters of people who had this feature
were aware of it they you know in that
open-ended text response they succinctly
described going into settings clicking
data usage and investigating that way
people who didn't have this feature
really had no idea a lot of them I guess
over twenty percent said that they would
check the settings panel because they
thought that would be an intuitive place
for this but unfortunately they didn't
actually have that feature a lot of
other people said that you know evade
call ver provider or they would call you
know Google or Apple who obviously would
have no idea and those support calls are
really costly so clearly the platforms
and the providers have an incentive to
making this you know information
accessible and so the conclusion from
this was that a lot of users are you
know incorrectly or not expect to see
this type of information in the settings
panels and so that's useful for like one
time system changes where something in
settings is modified what about ongoing
miss behaviors so you know imagine
something like you know vibrating the
phone constantly or playing music where
do people look for those sort of things
so any Android again there's a
notification bar there is on iOS as well
in this case you know you
this little icon that appears here and
users can expand that to yield more
information so here you know show you
who the texts from you know the text
message is from and you know maybe what
it says and so the question is you know
our users aware of this feature and do
they know if they can go here to yield
more information conveyed navino to
expand that so we did a laboratory
experiment where we basically
implemented all these attribution
features so we did one in the settings
panel and one in the notification bar in
our experimental condition to provide
attribution information for Miss
behaviors and then we had a control
condition which just was a stock version
of Android there was double-blind we
didn't know which phone people had until
after the experiment and so as I said we
had an ongoing annoyance in this case it
was vibration so during the experiment
we had one application just start
randomly vibrating the phone those in
the experimental condition would see
this icon appear and if they expanded it
it would say which I can't you know
which application it is otherwise in the
control condition the only way of
finding this information out is by going
through the task list and killing each
individual application until the
misbehavior stops when the phone stops
vibrating then it was probably the last
application that you killed for a
one-time settings change we modify the
wallpaper and android actually has this
you can change in two places you can
like click on the background and then
this widget pops up and so we annotated
that by you know adding this text here
so either by user or name of epic an
application or in the settings panel so
if you go through this thing's panel to
do this we also added a text annotation
there again only in the experimental
condition in the control condition there
really is no way of determining what
applications responsible if the
wallpaper is to change you can look
through like I showed you at the
beginning you can go through all your
applications to see which ones have the
ability but if you have multiple
applications with this ability installed
on the device there's really no way of
knowing which was ultimately responsible
so the goal for the study was to see you
know given these annotations whether
participants would be able to correctly
attribute the undesired behavior to a
specific app and also we designed the
experiment so that they had several
applications that were running in the
background all with the same permissions
so that any of them could have plausibly
been responsible so in our protocol so
we randomized the first two tasks and
the second two tasks i'm just showing
these as an example so you know in this
iteration maybe the wallpaper one was
first and then the vibration so we had
it what we're calling implicitly first
which was we you know we had it just
happen without drawing any attention to
it and we told participants that they
were there to review apps and so we had
them review three different drawing apps
drawing apps because each of them had
the ability to change the wallpaper and
then we had them interact with a widget
and the reason why we had them do that
is because then when very interacting
with the widget they'd be able to see
the the desktop background so that when
the wallpaper changed very likely to
notice it since these phones you know
required modifying the OS to implement
all this stuff we had to use our own
phones that we provided to them and so
we figured that if the you know if it
changed between tasks and they didn't
see it immediately change they might not
notice it the background change because
it's not verifone so you know one very
examining that widget we changed the
background we had be bird them and then
we looked at the reviews that we had
them right for each of the applications
to see if they mention this in any of
their reviews so whether they noticed it
and then without prompting them that we
did this and that this was part of the
experiment we wanted to see if they
would comment on it and if they would on
their own go through and use the
attribution mechanisms and find them to
try and identify the cause of this
misbehavior the second miss behavior was
vibrating the device so the other task
was playing with three different timer
apps timer apps because all of them
requested the ability to vibrate the
device and then as part of the you know
the fourth thing they did after those
three time wraps play with
dice app the reason for that was it was
a dice app that they had two shakes that
we could be assured that was in their
hands and so they felt it when it
started vibrating randomly and again we
looked at the reviews to see if they
notice this on their own and use the
attribution mechanisms on their own
after this we did I guess explicit miss
behaviors we told them you know you may
have noticed this happened before we're
going to cause one of the apps to change
the background you have five minutes to
go through and identify which app is
responsible so we did this in case you
know participants you know either didn't
notice it the first time or weren't sure
and then finally we had an exit survey
so what we found was you know for the
vibration in this case there was a
notification icon that appeared and if
they expanded that in the experimental
condition it would say the name of the
app and we found that you know
participants participants were
significantly more likely to attribute
the cause of this misbehavior correctly
when they had those mechanisms it was
about eighty percent in the experimental
condition compared to a little over
thirty percent in the control thirty
percent seems pretty high but you know
given for apps that's random guessing
and what we found was that two
participants in the control condition
actually did go through and kill every
app until they found the one that
stopped the vibration which is actually
a lot higher than we were expecting we
weren't expecting any people to to know
to do that which was interesting what
was also interesting was that on all the
devices we instrumented the OS so that
we knew exactly where they were clicking
on the screen and what widgets very
interacting with so we could go back and
you know check things like whether they
expanded the notification drawer at the
top and what we found was that you know
ninety percent of the people in the
experimental condition did but so did
seventy percent of the people in the
control condition so they you know
thought that looking up there might
yield some information so that suggests
that you know where we put it for the
other participants was a really
intuitive spot just those in the control
condition weren't able to find it there
wallpaper change so again it was this
was statistically significant but it was
only about thirty four percent the
experimental condition noticed it less
than eight in the control the difference
is you know
this is significantly lower than the
random guessing because every
participant saw this while they were
looking at that widget so most of them
didn't randomly guess when they were
wrong they simply blamed the widget the
very using at the time the misbehavior
occurred yet they notice Oh indeed fewer
people noticed it during the first task
so this was during the explicit you know
misbehave when we told them you know an
app on your phone just changed the
wallpaper you know figure out which is
responsible most people noticed it
during the first task they just didn't
commented on in comment on it in their
reviews because they weren't sure which
was actually responsible much many more
people commented on the vibration task
because I you know if they were using
one of the apps when it started or yeah
so anyway did you know this so this this
wasn't random guessing it was just
blaming the widget because that's what
they were doing so um you know most
people just admit it to random guessing
when they got it incorrect what was
interesting was that up to 20 20 percent
of the participants simply inferred
abilities based on UI features so for
instance the wallpaper change the
application that was usually identified
was one where participants somehow
stumbled on a button for change
wallpaper and so figured oh because
there's a button for change wallpaper it
must be this application because I
didn't see that button in other ones
when you know really you know the
features aren't the feet you know and
applications abilities don't necessarily
correlate with the UI elements the other
thing we had them do was in this the
second time they did this we asked them
to specifically identify an app we also
had them rate their confidence with you
know of the confidence in getting the
correct answer on a five-point likert
scale and we what we found was that you
know those in the experimental condition
not only were they more likely to be
right but they were also a lot more
confident in those decisions so even
those in the control condition who
managed to get it right did so with low
fidence so um you know this sort of
confirmed our previous findings from the
survey that you know where we you know
put these things in the OS were
intuitive to most participants one
question is you know in the second task
when they were doing the wallpaper thing
it was there was a significant
difference but it was only about thirty
percent were able to correctly notice
these attribution mechanisms should this
be considered a success I would argue
that yes because what we've seen in
practice is that usually there are a
small number of savvy users who tend to
explore you know these sort of features
and then they're the ones who end up
writing app reviews and a lot of users
put you know a lot of weight on the app
reviews so to give a good example of
this about a year or two ago Instagram
had changed their privacy policy to say
that you know all photos that you upload
our property of Instagram and can be
used for advertising purposes so
literature over the past 20 years tells
us that almost no one reads privacy
policies yet this was you know in the
New York Times the next day and it was
because there's a small number of people
who do and when they find something
that's really you know that really
defies expectations they disseminate
that knowledge and so even though you
know only about a third of participants
were able to use the attribution
mechanism here you know one that they
had never seen before which also might
be part of the small effect but you know
if something truly Bad's happening then
the few that are able to find these
these mechanisms will probably
disseminate that to the larger public
the public at large so the last part I
want to talk about is uh when these
decisions you know when when the
decision to confront the user with you
know a permission requests that you know
runtime is is necessary how can we make
those more informative so this is
actually work that i just presented at
chi
so we looked at here was I OS so iOS 6
which has been out for about a year now
added runtime permission requests for
five different things so any app the
request location contacts photos
calendars or bluetooth pairing there's a
runtime request like this that's shown
the first time the app requests that
ability once it's allowed then you know
the user never sees it again for that
particular app they can go to a settings
panel to revisit that decision but the
app never bothers them again what they
added though over previous runtime
warnings was the ability for developers
to add a sentence here to explain to
users why the date is needed and they're
actually no constraints on this
developers can use this feature they can
opt not to use it and they can supply
whatever text they want and so what we
want to look at is whether having this
information actually impacts user
behavior are people more likely to grant
permission requests when developers add
this text here and does the content of
it actually matter so given that
developers have enormous freedom in
terms of putting whatever text I want
there how much of a role does that have
in users making the decisions about this
and so the next question is then
adoption so given that this has been
available for about a year how many apps
are actually using it and you know what
our developers perceptions why do they
choose to use it why don't they use it
and you know when left to their own
devices what sort of text might they
include so we did an online experiment
again where we showed people screenshots
we did a couple different variations of
this and so we had a control condition
where we had a set of a dozen
applications and applications that did
have these strings and we just
photoshopped them out we showed those to
some people then we showed the ones with
the strings to other people and we asked
whether they would approve the request
and what we found was that there was a
statistically significant effect by
having this text there people were
actually more likely to approve
the effect size is relatively small but
there is an effect we controlled for you
know the order so looking at you know
when we did this within subjects that
didn't have any effect and also app
familiarity since we wanted to use apps
that actually use this feature we asked
people you know whether they've used
this app before how much do they trust
the app and we actually found that that
didn't correlate at all no no that's why
we so that's why we used existing apps
because we wanted to use text that was
actually used in the wild yeah studies
of the coffee machine right like yeah
yeah I was actually going to end it on
this so there are a lot more details of
the study which I could talk about but
we did a follow-up experiment where we
actually did vary the information
content and what we found was that there
was absolutely no effect based on the
text that we included they were in every
case significantly more likely to
approve it than in the control condition
so even in you know the the the no
information case that we used was you
know the app needs access to your
contacts because it needs access to your
contacts you know no information beyond
you know not having that string there
yet we found you know a significant
effect and so yeah what we found you
know we found that this is probably the
same effect as this famous study from
the 70s were bad people asking to cut in
line at the copy machine and giving all
sorts of excuses so you know in the
control condition was may I use the copy
machine but then they had this statement
saying you know because I need to make
some copies which doesn't offer any
additional information over the control
yet people were significantly more
likely to allow them to cut in line when
they said you know because I need to
make some copies which was actually
indistinguishable for you know providing
a real excuse so because I'm in a rush
and so this appears to be the same
effect that that we saw online which is
any explanation will do when people are
actually a lot more complicit when you
give them something we don't have a good
explanation for why but based on all of
our results from that experiment we have
you know some suggestions so one is that
maybe instead of letting developers
provide whatever explanation they want
we have some templates or a library and
so maybe at you know that at the time
the developers upload their thing to the
apple store the itunes store there's a
questionnaire that you know multiple
choice does the application use any of
the following data does it user for any
of the following purposes and so based
on you know the responses to those
questions you can machine you know you
can just automatically generate a
statement and the nice thing about that
is that it's consistent over time so you
know the problem with letting them
provide the text free form is that
they're you know thousands of different
ways of all saying the same you know the
same thing and so this way by having the
templates and having it machine
generated there might be some
consistency and then also of what you
know avoids having you know this placebo
condition of no real added information
and so with that I will leave it there
with the question it's interesting
because the xerox discussion among two
people right another mouth it's not
about me talking with 20 tons chain
above and me wanting to bring more
copies right I'm asking a fellow
colleague or someone else well the
example you gave is another corporation
is an app developer chief Facebook the
doing that and in between you have some
type of reputation a can of sprite
whatever they want something PPP to
write something or something if they
don't know what they did this thing they
want to say that the sea can say well
you are bc um yeah i think that you know
part of this might i think there might
be some human element to this which is
given that developers you know write
whatever they want here I based on so we
built a corpus of over 4,000 apps it's
in the chi paper and we were extracting
these strings from relapse and looking
at the variety of you know different
explanations in there I you know
obviously this probably correlates with
the size of the company but there were a
lot of you know ones that clearly had no
oversight you know things with typos in
them things that were just you know we
suspect were a result of developers just
not understand the API correctly and
having you know like code in there and I
suspect though that because there wasn't
a I guess editorial there were there
wasn't any editorial oversight that
might have created more of a human
element that this is it you know a
person who wrote this as opposed to
something in you know succinct I was in
stasis ain't legalese but that's that
might be an oxymoron something that's
you know heavily sanitized again we
don't have a good explanation for the
effect other than there was an effect I
think that might be part of it I think
another part of it might be simply you
know habituation so maybe by having a
wide variety of different ways of saying
the same thing
each of these dialogues look slightly
different so people make you know pay
more attention to them and are less
likely to you know click one button over
the other I don't know so I like the
trusted you I thing but one of the
challenges I see is that it seems like
it's going to be limiting flexibility
and style for design so you look at a
lot of apps they're trying to have their
own branding in their own style and
being highly designed in some way as
soon as you start imposing trusted you I
on top of that makes it harder to
customize that to the extent that that
wants to agree um yeah but yes that's
yeah that's something I'd like to
explore at some point we've been talking
about that looking at you know what the
impact is on developers and developers
you know willingness to use trusted UI
components it's not something that we've
looked at yet but I agree that that's
that is an important point I think
that's probably a big barrier somewhat
to this
I'm sorry to ask a question but there's
something I don't know it's sort of an
empirical question it feels as if there
are many different possible threats do
the same permissions errors and what
approaches to sort of batten down the
hatches and go after everything
holistically which is what you're
suggesting I actually the flowchart made
a lot of sense family a bit the other
one we did he's a little bit more
pragmatic and in that sense I'm
wondering out loud when you look at how
people are using permissions errors
today how are they doing it like what's
with the bulk of that permissions of use
and is that something that could be
special case out and you cut out 75
percent of the views without needing a
top-down and change yes and no I mean
someone i know because that's kind of a
moving target um jessica Lee you know
cutting a laughable every time yeah I
doubt have it just might mean the half
shows something else maybe yeah he says
that's why I'd say no on the other hand
I think the biggest problem that we see
right now just the real issue here is
looking at contextual integrity rather
than you know just you know is this
permission dangerous or not because
that's not what we're doing right now
and I think looking at is this on is the
use of this permission going to be
unexpected to this user and if the
answer is yes then maybe we should warn
them about it you know 25 text messages
got sent out by a nap I mean I can
imagine situations where like I download
something that immediately messages my
entire contact look like then you have
this an email right where occasionally
yeah and I get fish or something but to
be honest with some of these things i'm
having trouble come up coming up with
really deeply compelling threats I mean
yes you could share where I am with some
potentially malicious group but lots of
companies already know where I am yeah
actually location I didn't talk about it
in here but we did a lot of studies
looking at you know risks and people's
you know actual concerns over you know
various things that could happen using
their phone data and we found that
location is really towards the bottom of
the list which is interesting because if
you look at say the you know the privacy
literature from like the ubiquitous
computing community over the past 20
years locations the main thing that it's
focused on when in fact I'm not saying
that people don't care about location I
think that you know people still care
about location but relative to all of
the other things that applications can
be doing location is a relatively minor
concern okay so question uh yeah means
eight we've started looking at the
contextual issue I mean so in the case
in the case of location you know viewing
like Google Maps and getting a thing
about you know you know permission
requests for location is stupid because
you're habituating the user when you
know you know for using a mapping
application of course for expecting you
know location whereas angry birds then
that's unexpected because it's being
used for you know something other than
in app features and so being able to
disambiguate those cases I think that's
the next important step is being able to
determine what users will find
unexpected just based on context which
is something that you know we're not
doing right now so the comment only
sending out 25 emails raise a small flag
for the individual computer owner no
that's not a big deal but that's right
that's exactly how spambots work is
there's many many thousands of them and
each of them sends out some relatively
small number and so
role of your machine participating in
greater social ill becomes the problem
so it's not a problem to you yes I mean
snow could be a problem for you so the
reason why a lot of this I mean the way
that a lot of this malware was working
is the ones that send the SMS messages a
lot of them are sending you know premium
SMS messages that charge you know fifty
a hundred dollars to your bill you know
they have those like charity things
where you send the you know thing to
make a donation so a lot of malware up
you know authors are using that to incur
you know thousands of dollars on
people's phone bills which might be you
know under 10 messages now granted you
know if you call up the the phone
company and argue that it's fraudulent
you can probably get that reversed but I
think they're also relying on the fact
that not everyone's going to do that
yeah um so uh bringing up maps in
particular as an example leaking
location information some wonder if
there needs to be a place in this flow
chart behind for focus as means of
granting permission as opposed to just
put email in my focus so I'm fine with a
map application or other applications
which obviously need my location yeah
using my location when it has focus so
we tried but it can be especially me is
probably not you mean me the fact that
it's in the foreground yeah so focus in
the UI sons ok I thought you meant that
I might've meant something else which is
something we have looked at I thought
you meant focus as in that's the primary
use for the application that's the focus
of the application is mapping so one
thing that we did do is we tried to
train a classifier by looking at
categories of apps and whether there are
certain permissions that are you know
indicative of those categories and we
actually found you know very unreliable
you know correlations between categories
of apps and the permissions that are
requested but that that's something
different yeah I mean the same time
they're probably
different you know reasons why you're
having it requested in the background
you know might be useful in some cases
so for instance you know cashing the GPS
on your device is assisted because the
chip by itself is pretty weak and
running on just the chip you know
sometimes can take minutes to get an
accurate fix and so some of the apps
might be doing stuff in the background
to try and fine-tune that so that you
know the the UI seems less laggy when it
is at the foreground that's you know one
possible thing I mean I'm sure there are
probably other scenarios so you pointed
out a duration don't use it doesn't
scale um and I think some grub you're
making and you playing it in if you're
talking made a an observation that
there's a small number of users would
really care about these kinds of things
yeah and I wonder if that off that
offers a solution to the scaling problem
that you can have the equivalent of a
PolitiFact basically out there where the
OS is essentially allowing the the power
users who really want to investigate
these things to write say those
descriptions strings or to offer procon
um preach preach permission yeah
actually that's something that we have
talked about is trying to crowd source
some of this by having when there are
runtime permissions we then have a small
sample of people that we then have a you
know follow up to you know thing pops up
and asks you know what you know why do
you believe it was requesting this and
then there's a feedback mechanism that
puts the you know the responses from
that back into maybe reviews or some
sort of quantifiable thing on the app
download page that other users might be
able to take into account when they're
you know looking at the application so
you know when you see an application and
it says that you know ninety percent of
the users have no idea why it was
requesting access to location or fair
address book then rightly yeah then in
the pop-up that says you know why and
you know app check calm says well it's
this seems questionable
like that would probably have major yeah
yeah there's been some work on that I
think was a Heather lipford at UNC
Charlotte built this system where they
were providing these annotations for
facebook apps basically showing how many
people in there you know friend network
have installed this or you know approve
of this app and they found that that was
actually really persuasive to people
downloading apps last question today
with the whole idea of the explanations
are perfection I've seen some kind of
weird / on can I research worthy
questions in the intersection of that
with the trustee y components I've seen
some hats including a couple made by
friends actually we're on they as
developers want to be conscientious
developers and as part of their on
getting permissions they want to run at
runs I have little information stirring
about why they're asking for it yeah but
most trusted you like employments don't
allow for inserting that string
potentially for security reasons I'm not
sure why but so they have two on they
actually make it two dialogues one that
they control and one that if the answers
yes to that they then pop up the the
trusted component and have vaca actually
gotten flack for that from reviews
because it's two dialogues stopping
little bag to click through on have you
done any research in that out of many
streamline this idea of no I could just
say that we definitely observed that
that a lot of developers not a lot but
when we built this corpus of apps that
we were going through
we found that a lot of them have a
secondary well I guess a primary
dialogue the first comes up saying you
know that it's just a pop-up that
developed that the developer wrote
saying you know you're going to you're
going to see a request for this you know
for you know your contacts this is why
and it explains the reasons and then
when they click OK there then Bay get
the system drawn one I don't know how
prevalent is that practices we've
certainly seen it um I don't know how
whether it's any more or less effective
or yeah i'm just gonna interested in
from the developer perspective of um is
there like a temple for a way to
integrate be on the information line
with the system run dialog or is is the
security on flop potential they're just
too great what maybe issue there is that
it's it's annoying because that's an
additional you know unexpected dialogue
that's popping up and i think that it
points at this larger issue that you
know boo i guess those developers
believe that there's not they don't have
the ability to put you know to put the
pertinent information in these other
dialogues and so you know maybe that's a
yeah that points to the design of the
the runtime dialogues all right let's
thank our speaker one more time
you